we're looking at the slide rule I'm
going to show you why the same rule is
true if you really like variable formula
but why is it that and there's one
little way to prove it
there's a way that you'll see in your
textbook which which works quite nicely
however it has three different versions
because that aversion for when the angle
is the angles are acute the England's
right angle that the angle is acute and
you have to construct slightly different
triangles reaches with it something like
that okay so for each of those triangles
the proof of the sine rule looks
everything slightly different so you've
got that particular action so you can
read it at your own measure what I want
to do is show you a slightly different
proof that doesn't need different
versions but it does require a little
bit extra where computers build a
formula for another one pp knows which
is the area of triangle now this is the
result you should have seen before but
baby you're like I don't even know a
closed shop so I will show if you are
given any triangle you like and it's got
length a B and C for its size in order
to work out the area of this triangle or
the original formula we have for the
area toggle requires a base and what
else does it require it requires this
like here in the perpendicular height
right by the way it's important that
it's perpendicular it's not any height
but we so less than was so particular
concern because that's why we we sort of
abbreviate you 1/2 base times height
Assad's location okay now I want to
develop the other areas I know that
you've seen before which is more
sophisticated than half base times
height which uses tree so to do that I
think of angle 1 here being that I have
labeled my sides a B and C I'm going to
name my angles capital a capital a
capital C but how do I do it I do it a
picnic away not just randomly the entity
yeah so it is over here I was going to
say I'm across from their office is
directly on sir I want all that one
capital a and I'm gonna follow that
trend that make you capital B and
capital set and that's all five points
right now what I want to do is I want to
develop a formula for the areas that
doesn't rely on this perpendicular high
so I know that I should say area equals
complex on fire but I want to substitute
something else for that H right so what
am I going to do in order to get rid of
the age I got to find H in terms of less
you in terms of something else to the
trunk back it is in a variety ways but
right under fixed on its how they look
with me is a like another color have
this right angle triangle the left
inside okay if we focus or dis triangle
being that this guy is by the way it's a
particular head but they don't know what
it's called when you have a
perpendicular life inside a triangle it
starts with the letter A says no no
that's cool we call that the altitude so
if I have my something is directly above
we've got the Alpha to see which form
this right angle triangle over here so I
could just use regular right angle
triangle tree ratios in that triangle
but have a look you know if this is the
sign I'm trying to get rid of this flag
down here I actually don't know what
it's equal to
I don't let it be but I don't know how
much less to do so although avoiding
this side over here
I do know this side bird right so one
side is this image writing the triangle
it's about - people right and the other
angle occurs in this guide down here
which maybe is the opposite side does
that make sense so have a lot to keep
learning English language triangle us of
the hypotenuse I've got the side
opposite this angle
so which ratio will I use
sine is opposite over hypotenuse so
let's write this together I can say sine
C is equal to H n right
okay now remember my goal in trying to
write it down is to replace H resulting
so other than s H the subject here H
equals will have to do is multiply both
sides by hey and I bet okay
I test it I'm always there I'm not very
far off I'm going to return to my
original area of a triangle for naught
and I can say it's half B and instead of
writing
hi I'm going to write this same time a
sine C like so does that make sense
and now the familiar area equals 1/2 a
b9c images right what we've done is to
be transitioned away
you think those need to know the
perpendicular hi it comes a
perpendicular height sort of baked into
it for you do any two sides and which I
can tidy again quantum any angle which
one we are so famous special main
quarters in eight years we know that the
angular you've got it did one down here
it's between the two sides you chose and
that's important we call envy you might
want to label this we call it the
included angle that's raised ringabel
yeah one two three like Oh every day so
any two sides and he could angled ocular
here's where we get to the Sun what I
love about this formula in I started
looking at this side at this side but I
didn't have to write I could rearrange
all of the letters or I could construct
a different altitude and I would get a
different combination of sides and
therefore a different angle
Tauruses if I do choose and B if instead
I chose a and C I would write not this
but
a sign okay what's the included angles
it's beat up the top there play and
exactly the same way I would say well if
I didn't shoot a B or in C the last
combination is fancy so if I sure that
it would be signed a okay now this is
important this is the crucial step if I
can approach the area of a triangle in
any of these three ways and presumably
in singles so the area is the same I
can't operate on all of these things
together watch all right hop 18 sign C
is half AC sign e in half BC sign a I'm
literally one step away from the sign
rule once I've written this down okay
have a look
DC then you're coming back this here
right in the whole bunch of color sizes
and there are some things which aren't
cool in but if I divide through by them
anyway I'll get something nice and neat
I'm going to divide every single term by
a half ABC you will see why watch what
happens I get a high ABC there which of
course may never get one with you
what happens to all the heart they're
all gone right every detail of this
hardly double kicks with each other
that's good have a look at what else
gets left behind see how this is a being
cancels with this a B right this AC
cancels with that I think just make it
you get the IDE and so once you cancel
everything out you're left with sine C
on little C sine B on the way and a
little off forms okay and this is the
cycle that you know and love we only
tend to use one part of it right because
you're like oh if I'm solving for
something then I just need for example a
plan
angle I didn't know another angle is
opposite side and fish on site and then
you're done
so you don't need to use all three but
the point is what's really nice about
developing this way is you can see all
three are equal to each other because
that's just looking at the triangle
three away from trying so that's what
you've got so this is the sign on
there's another way to write X this is a
way that you write if you wanted to find
an angle if you wanted to try this side
you would write it slightly differently
all you do you would just rearrange it
it just will you turn everything to cut
that down right to your right see on
sign cb1 join me if you needed a third
one you would run a balloon animal
okay now it's a sable the same folder is
identical it's just as this save this
one step of 2013 upside down which is
what you'd have to do eventually okay